und in berlin bin ich jetzt verbunden
mit unserem hauptstadtkorrespondenten
mit erhard scherfer er hat beginnen wir
mal ein bisschen blumig wenn sie das so
gestatten sie sind ja in sichtweite des
reichstages und darum geht es ja am ende
des tages sind an anderen deutschland
hatte man immer mal gerne einen spruch
drauf motivationssprüche der lautete und
etwa so wo wir sind ist vorn und wenn
wir hinten sind es hinten vorn aber das
gilt wahrscheinlich nicht für wahlkämpfe
oder
naja für die union tatsächlich im moment
nicht mehr merkt das an diversen
reaktionen man merkt das ja auch an
diesem wahlkampf team und mit diesem
thema will die cdu csu oder wollen cdu
und csu jetzt offenbar wieder nach vorne
kommen markus söder hat das ja heute
vormittag dann auch mal sehr deutlich
und sehr demonstrativ bei einer
pressekonferenz mitgeteilt dass man
jetzt kämpfen müsse und dass man da
unter anderem auch auf das nächste
trient setzte und ja wir haben es
gesehen eben auch auf dieses achtköpfige
wahlkampfteam das ja ganz bunt
zusammengesetzt ist sowohl was die
geschlechterverteilung angeht auch also
was die regionen angeht und auch das
eine und andere schwerpunktthema ist da
abgedeckt worden und jetzt muss man mal
sehen ob das zieht die vergangenheit
wenn man die vergangenheit zu rate
ziehen muss man feststellen dass hat
nicht vielen kandidaten wirklich was
genutzt
er hat wenn wir ein bisschen noch
genauer auf dieses team schauen in wie
weit kann die system sie haben es jetzt
gerade schon in umrissen beschrieben
vier männer vier frauen auch die
regionale verteilung stimmt die
altersklasse ist ungefähr so sagen wir
mal mit dem schnitt ungefähr 51 aber
inwieweit kann armin laschet mit diesem
team wieder in die offensive kommen was
schätzen sie ein was hören sie in berlin
das ist traditionell tatsächlich etwas
schwierig deswegen habe ich dir eben
diese andeutung auch schon gemacht wenn
man zurückkommt die spd hat bei vielen
vorherigen wahlkämpfen ja auch immer auf
ein solches team gesetzt 1994 sogar auch
auf die berühmte troika hat nichts
genutzt rudolf scharping ist nicht
bundeskanzler geworden genauso wenig wie
die kanzlerkandidaten steinmeier und
steinbrück also da sind diese diese
expertenteams oder diese wahlkampfteams
oder wie man sie gelegentlich auch nimmt
schattenkabinett dann doch verpufft und
haben ein bisschen vielleicht im image
gedient und jetzt muss man gucken
das ganze bei der union in diesem fall
hier auf geht wie gesagt sie haben wir
das ganze schon charakterisiert wie sich
das ganze zusammen setzt auf der anderen
seite nennt die union ist ein
zukunftsteam oder armin laschet genannt
auf der anderen seite muss man
feststellen dass einer von den beiden
bekanntesten in diesem zukunftsthema nun
gerade nicht für zukunft steht nämlich
friedrich merz und deswegen ist die
große frage sein ob das ganze
funktioniert die acht wie auch immer sie
in den kommenden wochen drei wochen
ungefähr noch agieren dürfen ja auch
nicht zu aktiv werden weil dann stellen
sie unter umständen den
kanzlerkandidaten in den schatten und
wenn man sich das gesamt
gesamtgemengelage anguckt dann ist ja
nicht das problem die
unterschiedlich offensiv angesprochenen
themen und inhalte in diesem wahlkampf
seitens der cdu sondern der kandidat und
ob tatsächlich der kandidat von einem
backup team dass da jetzt aufgestellt
worden ist nochmal profitieren kann ist
die große frage schließlich misstraut
ihm die gute hälfte von unionsanhängern
den umfragen als einem der die nächste
bundesregierung anführen kann insofern
man darf ein bisschen zweifeln ob das
ganze funktioniert er hat vielleicht
noch ein wort sozusagen sie haben das
schon ein bisschen beschrieben wie
schwer das ist ein trend überhaupt
nochmal zu wenden so kurz vor einer wahl
wenn quasi ein gewisser grund zweifel
schon da ist sie haben auch ein bisschen
beschrieben dass wir von diesen acht
köpfen vor allen dingen einen der
zumindest immer als erster reihe
zuordnen können bei den anderen müssen
wir schon zum teil mal nachschlagen dass
wir noch mal vor und nachname gut
zusammenbekommen
hat sie auch überrascht wer alles nicht
in diesem team dabei ist den man hätte
erwarten können
ja das muss man zumindest mal festhalten
das ist doch das eine oder andere
gesicht gibt das im moment in amt und
würden ist das jetzt in diesem team
nicht dabei ist denken wir an den
verkehrsminister andreas scheuer denken
wir an die landwirtschaftsministerin
klöckner denken wir an die
verteidigungsministerin annegret kramp
karrenbauer und die kontaktliste noch
ein klein wenig fortsetzen jens spahn
beispielsweise muss man zwingend nennen
den bundesgesundheitsminister
auf der anderen seite muss man natürlich
sagen dass diese kompetenz teams
schattenkabinett wahlkampfteams wie auch
immer man sie nennen mag in der
vergangenheit selten dazu geführt haben
dass deren mitglieder dann auch
tatsächlich ministerin oder minister
geworden sind insofern werde der eine
oder die andere der aufgezählten die
jetzt nicht dabei sind vielleicht gar
nicht mal so böse sein denn die ganze
regierungsbildung läuft natürlich ganz
anders ab von denen die wir heute
gesehen haben dürften selbst im fall
eines wahlsiegs der union die
allerwenigsten dann tatsächlich wieder
ein ministeramt haben wo alle jetzt
drauf schauen ist wie deutschland
überhaupt was man sozusagen als
meinungsforscher zu diesem zeitpunkt
abfragen kann aufgestellt ist in
meinungsbild denn es geht um sehr viel
am 26 september die umfrageinstitute
geben sich jetzt die klinke in die hand
mit stetig neuen zahlen gestern war das
zum beispiel die ard deutschland trend
den wir hier nochmal komprimiert für sie
zusammengefasst haben wo wir einfach
noch mal sehen wie schwierig die
ausgangslage ist für die union - 7 im
vergleich zum vormonat mit jetzt 20
prozent die spd 25 5 vorn mit diesem
plus 7 die afd relativ stabil bei 12
plus 2 die fdp auch relativ stabil die
linke immer so kurz vor der todeszone
die grünen hier bei 16 die ja mal ganz
ganz vorn lagen das bringt uns dazu noch
mal mit unserem
hauptstadtkorrespondenten mit erhard
scherfer sozusagen teil 2 zu gesprächen
er hat wenn wir grundsätzlich noch mal
sagen wir haben uns das jetzt noch mal
gemeinsam angeschaut armin laschet sie
heute morgen haben es intensiver
geschaut
es geht ja darum jetzt 23 tage vor der
wahl noch einmal die trendwende zu
schaffen irgendwie den trend zu drehen
nach ihren erfahrungen wie gut kann das
gelingen
nach meinen erfahrungen ist das
theoretisch natürlich möglich in
wahlkämpfen auch in drei wochen vor ende
eines wahlkampfs oder also vor einer
wahl kann noch eine ganze menge
passieren wir wissen nicht welche
ereignisse noch kommen was sich weltweit
noch ereignet möglicherweise und die
insofern ist das natürlich alles nicht
wirklich zementiert und kann sich
tatsächlich noch ändern was auffällt in
diesen tagen ist dass die
umfrageinstitute jedenfalls die größeren
und bekannteren doch einigermaßen nahe
beieinander liegen und auch eine
ähnliche tendenz einen sehr ähnlichen
trend auch ermitteln bei ihren
jeweiligen befragungen und dieser trend
läuft halt im moment in richtung spd sie
haben es ja auch in ihrer moderation
schon gesagt und insofern wird das
generell glaube ich etwas schwierig
werden für die union das ganze noch mal
zu drehen auch mit der aufstellung eines
solchen kompetenzteams denn auch wenn
armin laschet jetzt fordert jetzt müsse
auch olaf scholz mal sagen wen er denn
möglicherweise an seiner seite haben
will in einer zukünftigen
bundesregierung was er nicht tun wird
was er schon seit monaten zurück war es
ein solches quasi schattenkabinett zu
nominieren oder gar vorzustellen
geschweige denn zu erwähnen das wird
möglicherweise auch von kritikern in
richtung armin laschet jetzt wieder
umgedreht werden und man wird sagen
irgendwie ja alleine schafft er es nicht
deswegen hat er dieses team aufgebaut
und andere die die szenerie beobachten
sagen dieses team hätte möglicherweise
schon vor drei vier wochen nominiert
aufgestellt und bekannt gemacht werden
müssen damit man wirklich noch einen
mittelfristigen oder kurzfristigen
effekt erzielen kann auf die
wählerschaft auf die eigene und wie
gesagt halt kernpunkt ist einfach der
kandidat ist ja derselbe da hat sich
nicht viel geändert und die in dem team
werden wahrscheinlich die allerwenigsten
ministerien dann betreuen insofern
dürfen wir ein bisschen skeptisch sein
ob das ganze noch einen effekt hat
er hat in der tat und vor ein paar
wochen war tatsächlich das fragezeichen
besonders groß wenn selbst eine relativ
konservative
tageszeitung wie die faz mehr oder
weniger titelt wo ist laschet aber sie
haben angesprochen die anderen die spd
die jetzt vorne liegen wo man vor einem
halben jahr noch überhaupt nicht in der
diese art und weise daran gedacht hat
was kann olaf scholz jetzt sagen wir mal
noch auf die füße fallen das kann noch
schiefgehen oder erleben dass von jetzt
23 tage raute
ja jetzt schon schöne beschreibung
glaube ich alles in meinen ich könnte
mir vorstellen dass er im nächsten teil
also in dem von ard und zdf ein klein
wenig lebendiger agiert als er das bei
dem von n-tv und der rtl gemacht hat
also das halte ich für denkbar und
ansonsten kommt eine relativ klare
botschaft aus dem willy-brandt-haus das
diesen wahlkampf machen wir so weiter
wie wir ihn angefangen haben das ist
auch die strategie gewesen von olaf
scholz von anfang an dass er gesagt hat
wir machen das auf meine art wir machen
das auch mit meinen themen wir machen es
auf die art und weise wie ich bin das
passt zu mir ich kann euch nicht sagen
ich kann euch nicht versprechen dass es
zu einem bestimmten zeitpunkt
funktioniert dass die umfragen sich zu
einem bestimmten zeitpunkt wenden aber
wir wollen oder ich will sind jetzt
meine worte ich will bei mir bleiben ich
will meine linie fahren irgendwie und
ich will so sein wie ich bin ich lasse
mich da auch nicht in eine bestimmte
rolle drängen das war ja ein problem von
martin schulz vorher an dass er
plötzlich viel zu viele berater um sich
rum hatte die im unterschiedliche
impulse auf den weg gegeben haben und
was dann dazu geführt hat dass martin
schulz am ende ich übertreibe seien
wenig selber nicht mehr wusste wer ist
das hat olaf scholz hier vermieden er
hat es auch mit den beiden
parteivorsitzenden geschafft das und dem
generalsekretär dass die partei sehr
geschlossen agiert wir haben ja keine
querschläge in den vergangenen wochen
und monaten gehört und ich denke mal die
spd hat für sich begriffen dass es nur
auf diese art und weise auch
funktioniert wir wissen wie
diskussionsfreudig die sozialdemokraten
sind aber die sozialdemokraten haben
verstanden dass wenn sie wir erfolg
haben wollen bei dieser bundestagswahl
sie auch geschlossen auftreten müssen
das ist bislang extrem gut und überfülle
für viele beobachter tatsächlich auch
überraschend gut und diesen weg werden
sie jetzt sofort setzen haben sie auch
für die kommenden wochen hat olaf scholz
auch konkret für die kommenden wochen
genauso angekündigt in der tat
überraschend diszipliniert die
sozialdemokratie in deutschland und auch
tatsächlich kaum ein hinweis von olaf
schulz wenn man mal von dem namen esken
absehen darauf wer dann mit ihm
gegebenenfalls einziehen würde in eine
regierung scholz die grünen müssen wir
noch schauen weil die werden mit spielen
in dieser oder jener situation bei frau
berbalk ist ja im grunde genommen jetzt
schon alles durch geprüft worden was den
lebenslauf angeht was eventuell
irgendwelche einnahmen angeht was kann
bei ihr noch schief gehen
naja die kanzlerkandidatur die die nicht
zum ziel führt also das ist ja glaube
ich mache das hauptproblem dass die
grünen haben in diesem wahlkampf das
sieht man auch an teilweise echt
dünnhäutigen reaktionen wenn man mal so
bei twitter sich durch guckt wie die
eine und andere reagiert auf bestimmte
situationen auch die spd reagierte und
auf die auftritte von olaf scholz
insofern muss man ja erst mal festhalten
dass das kernziel mich erreicht worden
ist und der konnte sich die partei
jedoch große hoffnung machen durchaus so
das ganze ist ja noch nicht mal vier
wochen her dass diese hoffnungen der
durchaus noch bestand gehabt haben das
dürfte nach allem was wir heute sehen
und was wir an umfragen sehen
gescheitert seien das zeigen ja auch die
bewertungen der jeweiligen drei kanzler
kandidierenden wenn die befragten
abgefragt werden wenn sie denn
eigentlich für den kompetentesten und
erfahrensten und mit blick in die
zukunft besten kandidaten halten landet
annalena baerbock ja glaube ich von
anfang an nicht in den lauf dem obersten
platz aber jetzt auch schon gar nicht
mehr sondern deutlich abgeschlagen von
olaf scholz insofern das eigentliche
ziel dieser kampagne ist verfehlt und
jetzt müssen die grünen gucken dass sie
platz zwei so vielleicht sogar mit ach
und krach noch halten können hängt
natürlich jetzt davon ab wie die union
sich weiterentwickelt aber unter
umständen gehen auch die grünen nur als
dritte dann bei der wahl ins ziel wir
wissen umfragen sind ja keine
wahlergebnisse insofern kann es durchaus
unterschiede noch geben aber so richtig
zufrieden wird man in der grünen
parteizentrale nicht sein denn hat ganz
herzlichen dank für diese informationen
hintergründe und einschätzungen direkt
aus dem herzen von berlin in reichweite
des reichstages dankeschön er hat die
hauptstadt danke